The number one AI tool that I would
recommend for all copywriters is this
tool at www.thinkforyourself.com
where it's going to point you to a
Moleskin journal that you can purchase
with a pen and you do this thing where
you open it and you immediately start
writing down ideas from your own brain
instead of some machine. And then those
ideas you turn into stories, those
stories you turn into emails, those
emails you turn into offers. And those
offers you turn into sales. And that
turns into a business when you become
good enough to do it over and over
again. So I would really recommend not
outsourcing every single thought into an
AI tool that everybody in the world has
access to. So you all end up with the
same crap saying the same ideas and
nobody cares about what you say cuz
you're just noise. Consider that and you
will absolutely crush